watermelon sushi
what hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome
back to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by skillshare
and we're going to be reviewing
vegan youtuber jacqueline forbes now
before we get
too far into things i want to chat about
what i've been learning through my
skillshare membership
while at home in these socially
distanced times
now if you haven't heard of skillshare
they're an online learning community
with a wide range of amazing creative
classes for exploring new skills
developing interests and getting lost in
your own creativity
i think a lot of us are dealing with a
lot of extra stress and anxiety over the
future right now
and also i know a lot of people may be
thinking about ways to learn some new
skills
and diversify in their careers so for my
birthday in december my hubby got me the
new iphone 12 pro max and it is pretty
awesome
so i've been taking a course called
iphone photography by amelie
satzger now this has been so helpful for
learning more about colors and equipment
tricks and hacks editing apps and more
and right now the first 1000 people to
click the link in the description
will get a free trial of skillshare
premium membership and then after that
it's only around 10 a month and very
quickly you can check out my general
disclaimer
on the screen if you want to pause the
video or take a look in my description
below but of course remember to be kind
and always there's trigger warnings in
there as well
now jaclyn is a 22 year old toronto
beauty and lifestyle youtuber
who got her start at the age of six on a
few nickelodeon films
today she posts a variety of vegan
recipes makeup tutorials
shopping hauls and other vlogs on her
popular youtube channel
and today we're going to be specifically
checking out her most recent
what i eat in a day on her channel at
the time of filming
please note that we are filming well in
advance for the sake of giving my team
some time off during the holidays
so if this one is not her most recent
one
don't crucify me alone
i'll also be speaking to general
patterns later on as well
all right folks let's see i've actually
really been into
black tea lately which is kind of unlike
me bring you a little packet
of stevia maple syrup also is fire in
your black tea as well
fyi
[Music]
oh my gosh before we even go anywhere i
need to just comment on how much i
love her mug bowl it's like a
bowl i mean this is just a baby mug this
is not even a good mug
at home that is how i do it too i mean
only
the biggest mugs will do all right let's
see what she's actually
gonna eat
okay so i'm gonna go natural peanut
butter on one and then crunchy almond
butter on the other
that's exactly what i'm struggling with
right now
okay i'm just deciding that this one is
going to be the uglier toes
and then this is the one that just needs
major help
okay that looks a little unwell there
she is a little brekky oh man
yep i effing love figs
and the jammier the better but also this
looks great
we've got a nice balance of fiber
protein healthy fats and carbs
and i love the sensory experience that
we have going on here
so she's done one slice with smooth
almond butter
the other with crunchy peanut butter and
combined with those sweet
juicy jammy figs and that combination
there had me kind of thinking i know
a lot of people think of almond butter
as the good nut better
and peanut butter as the bad nut butter
but
actually i want to just tell you that
they both have their redeeming
qualities now while almond butter has
about 25
more healthy monounsaturated fats more
fiber
and a little more vitamins like vitamin
e iron and calcium
peanut butter has a little bit more
protein ultimately though it all kind of
comes out
in the wash in the grand scheme of
things so choose the nut butter that you
like best
and enjoy or do like jaclyn does
and have both i would totally do that
let's see what's next
actually to be honest like not that
hungry right now because i've just been
in the house all afternoon
but i do have like an hour long meeting
coming up and then a back-to-back phone
call so i just am not gonna have time to
eat and i know i will be hungry
so we're gonna make a really quick lunch
it's basically like a little arugula
chicken
in quotation salad this stuff here so it
is like a soy product
i'm gonna take a little bit of oil and
then put the weird vegan chicken breast
thing
in the pan actually i'm gonna do the
flat side first so i've got some ontario
pesticide free arugula
then i'm just gonna cut up some cherry
tomatoes
okay and then straight onto the salad
so as you can see it's truly nothing
crazy but just like a really good
quick under five minute lunch idea
okay so i wanted to point out how jaclyn
mentioned that
she wasn't really hungry but she knew
that she should eat
because she had a really busy few hours
ahead now a lot of people who don't
really
fully understand intuitive eating would
think that this is
not being intuitive because she's eating
when she's not actually hungry
but this is actually really good
evidence
of an intuitive approach to eating being
able to
preemptively anticipate hunger and take
care of your body before it becomes
uncomfortable
is a great example of self-care now as
for her meal
this looks like a nice light lunch with
a good source of vegan protein from the
faux chicken there we've got fat in the
olive oil and
lots of veggies yes it's a little light
on carbs
but this meal is sandwiched between the
toast breakfast
and then later we're gonna see banana
bread snack so again
in the context of her day i think it
totally works
as for jaclyn's comments about it being
pesticide free ontario arugula
i assume she means these greens are
organic but it is worth pointing out
that organic doesn't necessarily mean
pesticide free so organic farmers can
still
use natural pesticides and natural
doesn't necessarily
mean they're inherently safer so one
example is
rotanone which comes from plants and was
used for
decades as an organic pesticide and is
now
no longer used in the u.s because it was
shown to cause parkinson's
like symptoms in rats also it's worth
pointing out that
one 2011 study found that almost 40
percent
of organic crop samples would have
synthetic pesticide residues on them
anyway
honestly i don't think we can deny that
synthetic pesticide exposure is greater
in conventional crops and organic
and that the safety of some pesticides
is
still up for debate but the current
research suggests that
the amount of pesticides that we
generally get
even in conventionally grown food is
safe
so if you want to choose organic great i
mean even i choose some organic products
when i can for my own personal reasons
but the claim that a product is
completely pesticide free
is a hard one to substantiate i also
looked into this pc
chicken product and shout out to the
fellow canadian products
um it looks pretty good so we've got 17
grams of protein and five grams of fiber
per
180 calorie chicken patty that's pretty
impressive in my books
i mean it's definitely something that
i'm going to be putting on my grocery
list
to try out in the next few weeks let's
see what's for snack
secret zoom eating banana bread this is
a homemade piece i have a recipe if you
want to see it
it's so good that looks like some damn
good banana bread and a totally normal
healthy portion to enjoy after a light
lunch
nothing critical i can really ever say
about a girl's homemade banana bread
other than the fact that mine might be
better so
shameless plug i'll link my recipe below
but anyways let's take a look at her
snack
with snack time okay i'm gonna sit down
read a little
this is actually that same pc
plant-based line that i was talking
about earlier
i tried this the other day and this is
so good onion and chai tofu dip
so i'm gonna put a little dollop of that
i've got some crackers honey crisp apple
because y'all know how i feel about
these
okay so big props to pc here in canada
for coming up with so many great new
plant-based products
also love me a good onion dip and
this one i looked up it has some great
fat and protein from the tofu
to pair with the fiber rich carbs in the
apple and triscuits
and if you're looking for a solid whole
grain cracker that doesn't taste like
cardboard
triscuits actually have three grams each
of protein and fiber per serving
so yeah that looks like an awesome
snack let's take a look at what she has
next the wonton soup here
which is so incredible perfect for a
chilly day like today
and then i've also got some rainbow
rolls here which they actually do like a
watermelon salmon
so these guys too it's like watermelon
which looks so crazy because it looks
like it's actually real fish but
obviously it isn't
so that is gonna be the feast tonight it
sounds um just so good
okay super fun so after her run
jaclyn ordered sushi from planta on
queen which i can vouch
is pretty great expensive like that roll
right there is
15 expensive but they do have
some unique innovative options for
plant-based folks
i also agree that the use of watermelon
as salmon is
pretty freaking genius like
mind blown
but because we're really just getting
veggies fruit and some rice
it does make for a pretty carb rich meal
without a whole lot else so
jaclyn if you're ordering from plant
again i would suggest maybe swapping
one of the sushi orders for something
like the hakka noodles with curry and
tofu
or the xo tofu and that way we get a
little bit more fat and protein to bump
the satiety factor up
all right folks let's move on to the
stats and trigger warning
i am about to talk calories and numbers
so feel free to skip ahead
but looking at this day plus a few
others that i analyzed for comparison
jaclyn's getting somewhere between 1900
and 2500 calories
and she's meeting her needs for most
macro and micronutrients from food alone
her fiber intake is also totally within
range which
very adequate but also not overboard
like some of the vegan influencers
that i've previously reviewed so that's
great and as for nutrients that she
isn't fully getting through food like
vitamin b12 vitamin d
calcium for example she's likely filling
those gaps with her supplements as
she does discuss her supplement regime
at length in one of the videos that i
watched
now let's talk about what i really like
here so i think one of the reasons
jaclyn's analysis was so glowing was
because she eats a variety of foods
most of the influencers that i review
have the same breakfast
same variation of a lunch and the same
snacks day after day
and hey i too am a creature of habit so
i know that this is also kind of a
personality thing for a lot of us
and it's also a time saving thing for
others for making meal prep easier and
faster for busy weeks
but when you just wing it in the kitchen
like jaclyn you get the benefit of
balance
baked into your meal so for example
since i watched a few of her wedding
today videos
i noticed that she would use flax oil
one day and olive oil another day to
yield
completely different fatty acid profiles
same with having oats one day for
breakfast or toast for another
or tofu versus lentils for dinner
variety is the spice of life
and i think we can learn a lot about
flexibility
from watching jacqueline cook i also
think that our meals are
simple and accessible and hinge on a
nice balance of convenient grocery store
shortcuts
and fresh homemade ingredients so these
are meals that
most people looking to eat more
plant-based could totally work into
their routine
now let's talk about some simple
strategies that i think jacqueline could
use
to really optimize her meals and snacks
first of all i can't really say that i
have a whole lot to critique here
i think even though her lunch was a
little low carb and her dinner was maybe
a little low protein
in the context of the whole day
everything
balanced itself out and ultimately
that's all that matters
in fact it wouldn't matter that much if
you had a super low protein high carb
day
as long as we were getting those
nutrients later on in the week
but if she wanted to optimize individual
meals she could throw her salad into
like a pita
or add in some quinoa or rice or add a
tofu dish to her sushi order to bulk
that up
now let's talk about jaclyn's
relationship with food
honestly i'm just gonna say it i think
jacqueline is one of the best vegan
youtubers out there right now
not only is she adorable and down to
earth and a pleasure to watch
i think she proves that eating
plant-based does not need to be
restrictive inaccessible overly
expensive
time consuming or just like massive
bowls of kale
she eats normal balanced portions of a
wide range of plant-based foods
and she's not cutting out full food
groups or volume
eating massive bowls of raw veg or
completely avoiding
fun foods and sweets she proves that
there's certainly room for
ice cream and hello dollies and banana
bread within a healthy caloric budget
so that you don't need to kill yourself
trying to eat
virtuous fat-free sugar-free
pleasure-free food
in order to meet your nutrient needs i
also just love that she shares a solid
balance
of laid-back assembly meals and snacks
and some inspiring homemade recipes on
her channel
especially in her bake with jack series
from apple crisp to peanut butter
cookies to the most insanely
delicious looking hello dollies i
love that jaclyn is all about normal
simple
everyday recipes that she's adapted from
her mom but just veganized
the way she talks about her meals also
suggests a really healthy relationship
with food
and a genuine desire to just fuel her
body
and her soul with food that feels good
to eat
she's not preachy or dogmatic in her
approach and when she does talk
nutrition
she adds a disclaimer that she's not a
doctor she's not an rd
and that her followers should get their
blood work done and speak to their
doctor
before starting any regime so
for those reasons and so many more
namely the fact that she always looks
so damn glam and i am jealous of anyone
who has time to apply
eyeshadow primer and feed themselves
delicious looking food
yeah i miss my 20s but anyways what i'm
saying
is that for so many reasons i think you
should totally give this girl a follow
and a watch
and a solid thumbs up we need more
youtubers in the plant-based space like
jaclyn
so on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today
thank you again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video if you liked it be
sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below and subscribe
to the channel